This work would not be correct, since we know that four-eighths would be equal
to one-half. More importantly, we know that this step cannot be correct. The
student tried to simplify terms in the numerator and in the denominator.
Remember terms are separated by addition or subtraction. We cannot cancel terms,
but we can cancel factors. Factors are numbers or variables that are multiplied
in the numerator or denominator. For example, if we started with six-12ths. We
can rewrite the 6 as 2 times 3, and 12 as 2 times 6. We can simplify the factors
of 2, since these cancel out to equal 1. This would leave us with 3 6. We repeat
this process one more time by rewriting 3 and 6 with factors. We can cancel the
3s, since they make an equivalence of 1. This leaves us with one half. So
whenever we're working throughout this unit keep in mind that we can't cancel
terms, we can only cancel factors, things that are multiplied in the numerator
and in the denominator. And finally, we know 5/8 cannot be simplified since 5
and 8 do not share a common factor. So we also need to include this reason.